all right deanna
deanna where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
and tell me about your family you grew
up with your parents no
i was adopted i got left in the hospital
when i was a month old
and i began i got adopted
then i got from my family was when i was
12
12 years old i found out that i was
adopted
and i found out my family was out here
that way
and they used drugs and i didn't know
so for me to get their attention
i started using drugs too tell me about
before you get into that tell me about
your life with the foster family
how was that yeah hard
they were strict i mean i had to sit and
they she she ran a speakeasy
so i was washing dishes and all that
type of stuff
and she ran speakeasy so when everybody
came
to get drinks or whatever you know i
mean i had to serve them drinks and
and all that and i mean and then
she served dinners and [ __ ] too so so
there was dinners
and drinks and then when they everything
was gone i had to wash dishes
and they flirted with me and
touched me a couple of times and you
know me and tried to tell her but she
didn't want to pay attention so
so did you run away i ran away at the
age of 13.
and you came to l.a came to la when i
was 14 i came
and then i left and i came back at 17.
you finished school i got pregnant at
14. no
i dropped out at the 8th grade you got
pregnant
yes i got a son he's 32.
did you raise him no
well actually i raised until he was five
then i started going to prison and you
know but
so when you came to l.a do you did you
find your real your blood
relatives yeah i found my real family
and like i said they would start
they was using drugs and to get their
attention i used to use drugs with them
and
my dad passed away and my mom she still
used up to this day
you know and she kicked me out because
she had
the dope dealer or whatever tried to
touch me and
so he put me out and she didn't want to
hear her because she was
getting money or whatever from me so
i don't know how long you've been living
on the street
how long i've been living in the streets
since i was 18.
wow and i'm still homeless
i get beat up
try to pay people to stay at the house
and
this and that it doesn't work you're
staying in a tent
right now yeah
you just stay wherever you can figure
out a place to stay yeah once in here
once in there and when you don't have no
money or whatever they kick you out you
mean right yeah so what's your drug
today
huh what drug are you using correct
correct
and how do you how do you support
yourself prostitution
you've been doing that since you were
how old 18
i'm sure you have some crazy stories to
tell yes i do
my life is a whole bunch of [ __ ]
i wish i could change it but
it is what it is what's what's been the
hardest part
what was the lowest point for you
losing your kids well
not letting my child know that i use
drugs
and and you know i mean
not letting them know what i had to do
to keep you know i mean to keep him
you mean and and then the lowest point
too
was when i first got arrested he was
there when i got arrested
and i mean and he was holding on to
something that that
direct like
i don't know man it's just low i feel
low
you've done a lot of jail time yeah i
did
since i was 18. my first term was eight
years
oh really what was that for direct sales
you have any friends no i don't have no
friends
you know you have friends out here like
this
they pretend like they're your friend
but they're not
if you have a hit you know me be your
friend if you don't have nothing
do you still have contact with your kids
today
yeah i do i have a grandbaby what
yeah i do but it's embarrassing because
if my son found out that i'm using it
again
he's not gonna let me know nowhere near
my grandbaby
you know and i'm still homeless i'm
still out here trying to do what i do to
get my drugs
you know and i have nobody
by myself you know i love my son
you know but i have no family i have
nothing out here
what's the hardest emotion to deal with
is it just being alone
alone
have you tried to get clean before yeah
i did
i had brain surgery
you know and i i cleaned for eight years
but well i
i just wanted to be with my mom and my
dad you know and that made me use again
trying to get that attention
it just hurt man
she's [ __ ] up it's almost like you're
cursed because the environment the
family you
grew up in
they they said when when words together
flock together or whatever
like when your family use or somebody
you know i mean it's in the genes that's
what they say
yeah but i don't know
i tried you know i mean but i just
i wish i had friends but i have none
no i want to get clean maybe one day
you know i don't want to let my son know
what i do out here
and and you mean what i've done and what
i've been through and none of that
you know when he was a youngster and he
seen me
you know when when i first got busted or
whatever with
with the you know he didn't understand
what was going on
but if he do now what was going on
i wouldn't let him know you know mommy
love you you know
i don't know man
do you take responsibility for the
situation you're in today yes i do
yeah because it's all mine it's on me
it's not nobody else
can't nobody make you do something that
you don't want to do but you can't
you got to take care of your own habits
you got to take care of yourself
the cracks are done nobody's going to
take care of you better than you take
care of yourself
nobody's going to take care of you
nobody's going to feed you nobody's
going to give you nowhere to stay
nobody's going to do none of that
you got to do it for yourself you know
and sometimes you gotta do what you
gotta do to have that
yeah but cracks are difficult drugged
yeah it is
you know you know sometimes they they go
is it what you make it no it's not
is it what you present yourself as
you know i don't know
you just got to take care of your own
habit can nobody do nothing for you you
can't do for yourself
and nobody love you more than you love
yourself
and i haven't loved myself in the years
but doing sex work for
for money is probably hard to love
yourself yeah it is
it is and i don't love myself at times
i don't
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
that i can lose my my life with this
have you had things happen to you there
yeah
things didn't happen to me where i can
be dead right now
you know god god didn't have me a gang
of times
he didn't have my back you know
he he's probably telling me you know
when is enough gonna be enough
but
what's the worst thing is happening i'm
here what's the worst thing that's
happened to you working the streets
got raped
you know somebody took me to the dead
end and rape me and put a gun to my head
[ __ ] me in my ass and stuff you know
meaning
still still out here doing the same old
thing
you know it hurts but nobody's going to
take care of you you got to take care of
yourself
if you could have changed one thing
about your childhood what do you think
would have made the biggest difference
if i had my real family and they weren't
addicted
and they wasn't addicted to drugs and
they had stopped
you know me be with me we all go out to
eat you didn't mean stuff like that
cookie you know me spend time with my
mom
you know mother and daughter thing do
you feel like you never really had a
chance
never
my adopted mom was abusive she always
used to call me all kinds of names
and stuff like that call me all kinds of
[ __ ] and hoes and
i'm just like my mom and i didn't know
my mom so
i was trying to figure out what was she
too you know why was she saying that to
me
but you know later on in life i figured
it out like
that's what she was saying but she
already knew
she knew that my mom was on drugs nobody
told me nothing until i was older you
know
i don't know
you still have hope yeah i do have hope
eventually imma imma snap a part of it
god gonna have me
all right dana well thank you for
talking with me
and good luck with uh
with your addiction it'd be great to see
you snap out of this
thank you
you